Well, I'm back with another Claude code
update. Today, we have auto mode. Auto
mode provides a safer long-running
alternative to dangerously skip
permissions. So, what that means is when
you're in Claude code and you shoot off
a message, you are in some sort of
permission mode. In this case, we are in
ask before edits. So, that means exactly
what it sounds like. Every time before
it does an edit, it's going to stop
working and it's going to ask me. Which
means if I wanted to step away or, you
know, work on something else, it would
keep interrupting my workflow. So, right
here you can see that it's able to read
things, but now when it wants to
actually make changes, it's going to pop
up this tab. It's going to say, "Hey, am
I allowed to do this?" You can either
say yes for one time only or you can say
yes every time in this session. And as
you can see, it's popping it up again
and stopping my session because it has
to make two edits. And it's not just
about the writing functions. Sometimes
it'll stop your workflow and say, "Hey,
can I do this web fetch or can I run
this bash command?" So, the other option
that a lot of people have been using and
what I've shown sometimes in my videos
is that you can use bypass permissions
mode, which basically means Claude will
do anything at whatever it wants and it
won't ask for any permission. Which
sounds great because a lot of times when
you're working on stuff, you just want
it to go through and not interrupt you.
But it's called dangerously skip
permissions for a reason because at the
end of the day, if you're not watching
it, it could go do anything. So, the fix
that I had been using for a long time is
within my .claude folder, I would have a
local settings file, which looks like
this. And this basically says, "Okay,
Claude code, you can do anything on your
allow list, but you can't do anything on
your deny list. And anything here, you
have to ask me explicitly before."
And so, this gave me a lot more control
over what Claude code does and what it
can't do. And in some cases, I still
think that this is the actual best
option to use because you can change
these per project and you could also set
this globally if you'd like. But with
Claude code's new release of auto mode,
it basically makes those permission
decisions on your behalf. So, now
instead of having to copy and paste this
settings file over to all of my new
projects, I could basically just come
into the permissions mode. I could
change this to auto mode right here,
which says Claude will automatically
choose the best permission mode for each
task. And you can do this in VS Code
like you're seeing me do right here. Or
if you open up a terminal and you run
Claude like this, which is Claude enable
auto mode, it will launch up Claude and
then when you shift tab through, you can
see that we now have the auto mode
setting. And right here you can see that
it says auto mode let's Claude handle
permissions automatically. Claude checks
each tool for risky actions and prompt
injection before executing. Actions
Claude identify as safe are executed
while actions Claude identifies as risky
are blocked and Claude may try a
different approach. It's ideal for
long-running tasks. Sessions are
slightly more expensive. Claude can make
mistakes that allow harmful commands to
run. So, it's recommended to only use in
isolated environments. So, auto mode is
the middle path that lets you run longer
tasks with fewer interruptions while
introducing less risk than skipping all
permissions. And that's pretty cool
because basically
before every single tool call, a
classifier reviews it to check for
potentially destructive actions like
deleting or sensitive data, things like
that. So, basically it reduces risk, but
it does not eliminate it entirely. And
we also did see in the terminal, if I go
back over here and go to the terminal,
it basically said here that these
sessions are slightly more expensive
because I'm assuming before every tool
call, it uses AI to say, "Hey, is this
dangerous? What should I do?" And that
would explain why it's more expensive.
So, like I said, in order to use this,
it is right now research preview and
it's only available for Claude team
users. But if you are on a team, all you
have to do is you come in here and you
go to your organization settings and
then you right here are able to enable
allowing auto permissions mode. Same way
that you would allow bypass permissions
mode. And then you guys saw earlier, all
we had to do was we had to run this
command right here, Claude
enable auto mode. Or if you're in VS
Code and you're just using it like this,
you should be able to see it right
there. And then also, if you want to be
able to disable it, you can do that like
that. So, anyways, I know that was a
super
quick one, but I want to keep you guys
up to date because I'm talking and
shipping every single day. So, if you
learned something new or you enjoyed the
video, please give it a like. Definitely
helps me out a ton. And as always, I
appreciate you guys making it to the end
of the video. I'll see you on the next
one.
Thanks, everyone.